on this particular occasion went into  Prince Andrew's bedroom and his  apartments and on his bed was I now know  was 72 I said about 50 but I may confirm  it was 70 tokerchetta Canton 72 teddy  bears on his bed and then my inspector  showed me a laminated card which is in  the side  um side draw  one of the bedroom cabinets of a picture  of these teddy bears all in situ and he  said the reason for that picture is that  the mice have to put them back exactly  like it's in that picture they said if  they don't he shouts and screams and  abuses him and then a mate came came out  and confirmed that she had to do that  otherwise he would shout and scream  so you know that's not not really the  actions of a  sort of a nice person you know to have  people having to do that he's a very  um  self-entiled person I mean more so than  any member of the royal family  um he's stuck out like a saw thumb  no one liked him